and we had talked about how one day
there will be a global pandemic of this
nature and it's
really quite astonishing that this is
actually happening now
[Music]
all right i'm me mac thank you for being
on my show how are you
i'm doing well how are you michael i am
doing just fine
as you were both talking from the bay
area right
but you you actually have something very
very relevant to what's happening today
and you're at the director of
translational medicine
at the genome center within stanford
medicine right did i get that right
that's correct the stanford genome
technology center
okay so what does that mean what does
that mean that you're leading the
translate
translational medicine sure
so um first of all thanks for having me
on this show
of course great job this is wonderful
and very exciting
um and so at stanford
your alma mater the the stanford genome
technology center
is a center where we use genetics
microbiology lots of different
technology work with engineering
and it's a multi-disciplinary group that
really is involved with lots of
innovation
and new product development used to
study
all sorts of different uh healthcare
related problems as well as
biotech type of type of problems so
i work with dr ron davis and he
was one of the uh leaders in the
development looking at the human genome
wow okay that that's amazing and
actually you know your
your life story is very unique and and i
think that that's what i want to
i want us to start because you're
starting out as as a patient yourself so
you're a swimmer exercise enthusiast
suffering
a chronic disease of lower back pain is
that right
yeah well you know low back pain was
just part of my story
um to be quite honest this was a this
has been about a 20-year journey
and so the reason translational medicine
is so important to me
is because it really um is a field in
which
you have to understand your the patients
and what their needs are
you have to understand what research is
doing like what researchers are
looking for in doing and then you have
to be able to take
all of those things together bridge
physicians researchers and patients
needs
and come up with the most strategic way
to get to a goal
and so um really understanding what
the needs of the various stakeholders
that are involved in
for example um designing a diagnostic
test
or um you know learning how to use yeast
for all new
sort of purposes um you really kind of
science can be done oftentimes in a way
that is
very um nuanced
and so being able to guide researchers
to say
this is actually what's relevant and
this is what the patients
need is really where i fit in
okay now and but but you know you're you
have the unique position of
you know transitioning from patient that
you think 20-year journey
underwent you know a massive surgery and
you you know you you can empathize with
the path that a lot of people
in similar situations not necessarily
the same disease per se but different
situations are are facing and then you
are transitioning to being a physician
and now you're you know you're being
acting as a researcher and trying to
innovate past what is what we know today
right
that's right so about 20 years ago i had
mononucleosis which is a very common
um viral infection epstein-barr virus
95 of the population actually has it but
somehow for some reason in my immune
system
that virus triggered something and
caused an immunodeficiency
and therefore i became more and more
sick um
ultimately i was diagnosed with a
condition called chronic fatigue
syndrome
which is now currently named myalgic
encephalomyelitis
and you know i i understood the first
one the second one i didn't understand
it is a mouthful we call it me for short
and you may have heard a little bit
about it because now with covid19
um what we're finding is with sars
patients covet 19 patients
patients who've had all sorts of other
communicable diseases
many of them end up with this
unrelenting sort of
fatigue as well as other problems
dizziness brain fog difficulty thinking
and so what we're doing at the stanford
genome technology center
is we've heavily put many of the
resources
towards trying to come up with a
diagnostic test for this illness
and solving the illness and looking at
its molecular underpinnings
crazy you know that's exactly why i love
this show so much because you know we're
preparing to do this
episode together and out of the blue i
get an email from you saying like
like michael just fyi we're working on
you know on this crazy development
that's happening with covet and
where the front and and and i'm so
excited to talk to you about that
what is it like being now on the
forefront and discovering
with the world but a little bit before
the world how
you know this this unbelievable pandemic
is taking its shape
like really really trying to to make
sense of all the confusion there
well to be honest at times it can be
frustrating because we see things ahead
of time
and you know as scientists researchers
and physicians
there's we need to
certain things using research however
based on prior viruses we can have some
idea of what is in store and have some
predictions
um i was speaking with my my colleague
and boss dr ron davis about
two years ago and we had talked about
how one day there will be a global
pandemic of this nature and it's
really quite astonishing that this is
actually happening now
so um to be doing the work that we're
doing
it's it's very exciting
and the way that i look at it is you
know there are so many things from a
scientific perspective
that we need to still learn um but to be
able to be right
at the leading edge of discovery
um is so so exciting
and what i really would love
people to know is that you know i had it
i had an illness um i went through
medical school i went through residency
i went through fellowship training
practiced as a physician
ended up here did some work with uh
healthcare and technology
and really dove deep a long time ago
into app development
and how we can use mobile applications
to really understand what's happening to
humans
and at this point now we have wearables
that can plug into apps we have all
sorts of really
cool innovative techniques to gather
data
so that we can tell patients stories and
connected to the research
because oftentimes we do all these
really great
molecular and genetic tests and whatnot
but what we're
trying to do is get real-time data from
people and make sure that that's clean
and precise data and that's a huge
challenge
but somebody's got to do it right 100
and you know so you know take me a
little bit about talk to me a little bit
about this journey of yours as a
researcher
and you know coming in as somebody who
you know a young entrepreneur
software engineering i don't get exposed
too much to biotech and and
work with genomes and understanding the
human body the way that you do
how do you even get it started in this
field and how do you
look what's your day-to-day like oh
that's a great question
so my day-to-day is very different i
don't have
you know a typical day and what i'm
asked to accomplish in the center varies
depending on which team
i'm working with right for example um
right now i'm working on a project where
we're developing an app
so that we can continue to collect data
from patients who have covid19 to see
what percentage of patients end up
developing this chronic long-standing
condition
so recently chris cuomo um
on cnn stated that he also has this
condition
and anthony fauci has also talked about
how so many people are ending up with
long-standing long-term
uh debilitating issues as a result of
growth
and so for me this has been my life's
work and i'm so passionate about it
because i was one of those people who
was never supposed to make it
i was one of those people who was too
sick to finish medical school or too
ill to do residency and so you know
for me finally doing my own research and
figuring out what was going on and being
able to maneuver health care
because as a physician i understood how
the health care system worked
um for me that that's a great story
personally but what i could what i have
concerns about is what about the people
who don't know how to navigate the
health care system
how do we plug them in and then how do
we get people like you michael
to come and help us parse through all
this data use artificial intelligence to
make sense of
the voluminous amounts of data that
we're getting and to really help us find
answers and clusters and um
uncover a lot of problems that we find
especially the immune system
and the immune system is extremely
interesting and it's kind of
um we know things but there's a lot that
we don't know
and we need people to help us from the
data side we need people to help us from
the technology and wearables side
we need you know fun engaging apps we
need to present
combine that with the researchers i
think that's i think that's in
that's incredible i'm actually very
close to it to a startup back in tel
aviv called immune ai
they just recently came out of stealth
mode and that's and they're trying to
use artificial intelligence to uncover
the immune system and to and to help do
research on that front
but then you know coming in as a
researcher how do you you know as a
doctor
now think about this integration with
engineering and artificial intelligence
because i'm assuming that most
doctors in your position don't
necessarily have you know the
technological expertise of
years of dealing with data and all of a
sudden you're
you understand that in order to really
make sense of the research you're doing
you're going to need
support from people who have no idea
about what you're doing
but they're experts in artificial
intelligence and you have to find this
this weird combination right yeah yeah
so first of all i have an amazing father
who is an engineer and computer
scientist himself
so being around a lot of computer
science people growing up
um you know i recognize the
need for technology to really help us
solve problems so he was in supply chain
management so i was able to apply his
supply chain management
um theory to how to run a practice
fluidly
um i think that i'm fortunate in that i
work with such
amazing brilliant researchers and
they i'm learning every single day
um so how i ended up here to be quite
honest i kind of let life guide me
um it was quite serendipitous um
i had done genetics research in
undergrad and i was thinking about doing
an md phd but they didn't have an md phd
program at the time so i just did my md
but unfortunately i became ill
and so i got kind of frustrated at being
both a
medical student and a patient
so afterwards i really i left medicine
and i worked with an internet startup
company
and then i also so we were doing ui ux
before ui ux ever even existed
when are we talking about what year is
this this was
2 000 and 2004.
wow right 2000
wait but but that started it it was in
the medical space right
no actually it was completely different
completely different it was a language
learning company called mango languages
and it's still in existence
and they're doing wonderfully but i
always wondered where all of these
different um experiences
i had when it would all come together
and
then i was able to apply ui ux and what
i had learned about that
to creating mobile healthcare apps i
worked as a
upmc university of pittsburgh medical
center in harvard and we had done a lot
of work on creating an app and i've done
some advising in the past
wow being able to integrate um
just these various experiences if
there's one thing i would say to people
is don't be afraid to try something new
because
the convergence of
learnings from different up from
different fields
is really where innovation comes from um
it really teaches you to think
differently and i encourage people
you know there's a lot of times students
will say to me oh my gosh i want to take
time off of school
you know but my parents don't want me to
and i'll sit down and talk to the
parents and say
you know what that experience one day
will really serve
you know your son or daughter really
well so don't be afraid to try new
things because one day
just like in my life now everything
manages
to make sense and come together and all
of a sudden now you're dealing with you
know the same disease that you
had to deal with for 20 years but now
you're dealing with it from a research
perspective
and and and what are the implications
and how to help others
through it but but i mean then then talk
to me a little bit about this you know
teaching style and mentorship
you're alluding to that and right before
our call you know you mentioned to me
that that is one of the things that
you're really passionate about
so so what it what is teaching for you
or mentorship
guiding others through their own journey
which like you're mentioning is
is very sometimes difficult to do when
you're getting you know very
a lot of pressure from different sources
and it's hard to navigate your own path
so to me i was very fortunate
i started my residency and joined our
academic association the association of
academic positions
and there i was very inspired
because we had lots of physician leaders
that took all of us on and what i
learned is
you can never have enough mentors
because each mentor
may have something different to offer
you know one might be
more interested in media affairs another
might be more interested in technology
and there's so many different things you
can learn from each one of them so i
always tell people don't be afraid to
seek out as many mentors as you can
um and for me one day when i'm gone
it's important to bring other people
into
who will be doers and who will be
thinkers and
who are excited about forging ahead you
know we're living right now in a very
tumultuous time
yes tumultuousness doesn't mean that
we have to fade away it means this is an
opportunity to
really seek deeply what's in your soul
and pull that resilience out and say
what can we do to make this better
because there's always been times in
history where there's been scary things
that have gone on whether it be wars
this that or the other thing
but it's really the people who pulled
themselves up and said how do we
fix this that's really what pushes
um pushes humanity forward
and i think one of the greatest uh one
one of the most common phrases
of the stanford business school is don't
waste a good crisis right
yes i don't remember who coined it i
think it was one of the maybe it was
churchill or something
but uh but but i think no i think it's
very true and it's not just in the realm
of
you know how to leverage you know
economically a crisis that's happening
and that's a lot of what entrepreneurs
go to but also
how do you know in terms of mentorship
and teaching how do you take this time
of introspection and understand
what you want to do and i have a lot of
people that i speak to that have been
taking this
time out and and sort of reevaluating
what their priorities are
what you're forced to do when you're you
know when all of a sudden you don't have
all the experiences outside that are
sort of like noise
that don't allow you to to look
internally right absolutely you bring up
a really good point
breaks for self-reflection are really
important
because otherwise you end up on a
completely different path than where you
want to be
it's very easy to hold in different
directions sure
i mean what are you excited about what
really you know gets you up in the
morning and
makes you feel so passionate and glowing
throughout the day
first of all learning you know there's
i also still continue to have mentors so
every day
learning about what we can do with
healthcare technology all the research i
mean
reading constantly throwing myself into
the work but what really excites me
is this disease that i've suffered from
for 20 years
that has received
very little um attention and very little
funding
um unfortunately there's a
pandemic but fortunately we have the
opportunity like you said
now to study this and understand
what's happening and you know
it's too bad that it took a global
pandemic for us to
be able to seek out the answers to what
is happening inside of the body as
people transition from getting a virus
and what happens long term
but we have to grab it with both hands
and so for me you know
trying to let people know what's
happening and get funding for this kind
of work
and speaking with the uh with the
different researchers and talking to the
fda
about how we're going to get things
improved but what really grabs me
is you know how we can leverage
technology now to answer
questions that we could never answer
before um
there's so much data out there and so
we need technology to be able to really
parse through
all that information that's coming at us
yeah and i mean that's exactly where i
think the world is headed right now
right we're seeing this boom of
understanding that
that now we have to leverage data
science with the work of researchers and
doctors like yourself to really make
sense of
what's happening and and i i'm
personally very very
excited to see where we're headed and
and what's going to happen in the next
few years
i'm especially excited to be a part of
this transition and and have and get my
own hands dirty with it with a lot of
this work
i mean before we leave i have to ask you
the most important question three words
that you would use to describe yourself
um let's see
inquisitive okay um
fears fierce what does that mean
fierce means
peace means seeing that something's
challenging and going for it anyway
okay not being
so i guess the next one would be
confident confident that you can
you will figure it out and resilient
inquisitive
fierce and confident i love that i think
that's exactly what it takes to do the
work that you're doing
so no surprises there
definitely yeah michael it's been oh no
thank you
this was this was great thank you for
your generosity thank you for your time
this was just inspiring
i'm i'm personally i think that it's you
know i can't wait to get deeper into
this world and understand it better
because this is where the impact is at
the end
and then it's literally you know saving
lives and making you know helping people
going through pain live their lives
better healthier and in less pain
and you know coming in from the data
science side myself i'm just excited to
see this
this harmony i'm very excited the one
last thing i do want to
let everybody know is that
we estimate that 2.5 million americans
have chronic fatigue syndrome or myalgic
encephalomyelitis
and there's been less than five dollars
per patient
of nih monies that have been put towards
this
wow just to give you a little bit of
background there's 950 000 patients with
hiv
this is 75 of patients with this illness
are either home bound or bed bound
cause of disability so if you think
about it about
at least 10 percent of patients with
sars developed this
now if 10 percent of patients with stars
ii or covid19 develop this we have a big
problem on our hands
so we really have no choice but to
really
you know figure out what's going on
because perhaps we can prevent things
from happening to other people it can
destroy lives
unbelievable amin thank you very much
for the inspiration
you're michael stay safe and stay out
i look forward to chatting again take
care bye
you